In this lesson, we're gonna take a look at parent materials
and instance materials and how to add new features
to get your material to be a bit more robust.
So let's get started.
So one of the things I'm gonna emphasize
is make sure that you work from a parent material
and you make and always get in the habit
of making instance materials from those parent materials
and then apply those instance materials to your objects.
The reason why you wanna do that
is you can actually control a set of parent materials
where one handles translucency,
another one handles flesh,
another one handles hard surface organic,
another one non-organic.
You can actually categorize things in such a way
and make instance materials from those parent materials
to have quick control over your environment
without having to recompile your shader.
So this is a very optimized ideal way to work in Unreal
to get changes quickly done
and to be able to swap out textures.
As you can see here in the instance material,
we have quick access to these
and we can also control variables.
Let's briefly take a look in Unreal
at what I have set up for you.
So in Unreal, we have a sample material.
This one's just a little shadier
than probably what you have in your scene.
Don't worry about it, it's still the same thing.
And this is concerning our first topic.
Now I'm gonna double click on that material
and we can see that we have full control
of this material.
And we have several sliders
as we can swap out also the texture.
You'll notice down below we have a metallic switch.
Now yours is probably off by default,
but with it on, you'll notice at the top,
we actually have a metalness area.
And I just loaded a simple blank white texture.
In the parent material, these can be any textures
because in the instance as we're in here,
I can swap them out at any time.
So if we turn this off, you'll notice now
we have the ability to control our base material
via a slider and that'll control our intensity
outside of a texture.
Let's move that back to default.
And if we turn that back on metallic,
you'll now see the texture populate.
And that's what we're gonna build.
We're gonna build this in Unreal.
And this is what you call a static switch parameter.
It makes it a lot easier for your material,
especially if you don't wanna actually use
that 4K material for an object in the distance.
You can turn some of these off.
Now there are some things in Unreal
that automatically do some of this for you.
That's it for more of the advanced classes.
And we're not gonna get into it here.
Let's momentarily get back to the slides
and then we're gonna jump back into Unreal
and build some of this.
So step-by-step I'm laying this out.
So feel free to follow along
and you can even use that material sample that I have
that'll help you and point you in the right direction
as you're building things out.
So let's go ahead and start building
the static switch parameter.
I'm also gonna point out to you a few other ways
you can build nodes to make your material
a little bit more stronger in the use and function
and to just make it more robust.
And then we're gonna take a look at that UVs up close.
So here in Unreal,
I'm gonna move this out of the way for now.
And we're gonna go and make our own material.
Let's go and right click here.
We're gonna put it on this white object here.
I'm gonna click on material
and we'll call this M underscore demo.
And I'm gonna double click on that material.
He's off screen, but we'll pull him into screen.
Here we go.
That's better.
Now at any time you can go in here and again,
open up that material that I've made
by simply double clicking on it.
But I wanna point out if you've forgotten,
you wanna go to the parent material
if you wanna see the structure
and what I'm gonna be building.
And that's gonna be helpful for you.
Let's go to our homegrown material here that we made.
I'm gonna go full screen
so you can see everything as we're building things out.
I'm gonna cheat a little bit
and I'm gonna borrow that first part
when it has the albedo information.
Cause we already went over that in the first class
and we wanna make sure we're using our time efficiently.
So I'm just gonna copy this for now
and I'm gonna paste it into our scene.
And then we're just gonna connect that to the base color.
If anytime you wanna be able to have a quick way
to be able to make a scale of parameters
such as this little guy here
and have it directly connected to any of these nodes,
execution nodes here,
you can actually right click the metallic
and say, promote to parameter.
And then look, hey, we have a metallic control
or even specular, right click, promote to parameter.
Like that, we have specular control.
And that's really up to you
but that's a quick way to do that
and saves a bit of time.
We're gonna make our own metallic
cause we're gonna create a switch for it.
So I'm gonna delete this part.
What we wanna do now is go in here
and make our metallic texture.
So I'm gonna actually borrow that texture again.
It's just a white blank texture.
I'm just gonna copy this from the original
and just paste it in here for now.
Next, I'm gonna go in here
and I wanna make a multiply
as well as a few other things.
Now we'll keep this metalness.
We don't need to change the name.
Keep my finger on the M key, left click.
There we go.
Keep my finger on the S key.
Now, if I want, I can do a promote to a parameter
to have it quickly connected to that B
and just rename this.
And we'll call this metalist intensity.
And if it helps you, you can say texture driven.
And we'll make sure we set that to one.
So it's always on.
I'm gonna connect that texture that I have.
And again, I'm just using generic one.
And now we can make a switch
which will derive between us going in here
whether we wanna use a texture
or we wanna use a scalar parameter.
To do that, I'm gonna right click in here
and type in scalar,
or I should say static, sorry.
Static switch parameter.
There we go.
So we need a static switch parameter.
My apologies for that.
The static switch parameter is gonna make it
so we can flip between the texture
and using a scalar.
I meant to mention scalar,
but I for some reason called him that temporarily.
Sorry, Mr. Static switch parameter told me to offend you.
We're gonna call this here metallic.
And if we want to,
we can just put a question mark
cause like whether you're using texture or not,
it's up to you how you do that.
We can't promote this one
cause it requires logic in here.
So what we can do is just keep your finger
on the S key and left click.
And this is gonna be our base base,
no texture metal.
I'm gonna put that right into false.
And I can leave that at zero and we'll be fine.
Multiply it to true.
And then we're gonna connect that to metallic.
So now if I apply this,
we find that material,
let me lower this just a little bit.
I can right click in here
and say create an immaterial instance.
If we go into this material instance,
I'm just, I'll dock this here.
We can see we have the albedo,
albedo tint, albedo intensity there.
We also have base, not metal.
So we can control this here,
not metal, texture driven.
But if we want to, we can turn on the texture part.
And when we do, it shows up to the party and there it is.
And we can control the intensity of that down below.
Now again, I haven't grouped these.
We've already talked about grouping.
So we don't need to group this.
You guys kind of get the idea of that.
And to save time,
I haven't grouped them in this particular case.
And then now we can control
how strong that's going to be.
Pretty sweet using that static switch parameter
that keeps things a little bit cleaner
and makes it so that if you need to switch them
and you don't need that texture information
can make things a bit lighter.
There are other areas
where you can actually make things a bit more complex.
And this is derived from my sample.
And I'm copying this particular group of nodes
and just want to point them out real quick.
So this set of nodes that I have here,
this allows us to go in here
and even have a cheap contrast,
as well as actually be able to control the albedo tint.
So if I wanted to plug that in,
I would have that ability to do that.
Now there are multiple different ways to get cheap contrast.
And obviously this is called cheap contrast,
and this allows you to be able to do that.
Now, these things we're going to talk about later.
These are called material functions.
These material functions allow materials
that have functionality,
and they open the doorway for us
to actually make a more customized look and feel.
And that'll be towards the end of this course.
Let me go and delete this for now,
because we don't really need it.
Let's go and make that UV set.
That's going to make things look a lot better.
So to be able to handle or edit our UVs,
we're going to need a couple items in play.
One of them is I keep my finger on the U key left click.
This is my texture coordinates.
The texture coordinates here,
I'm going to keep my finger on the M key
and we get multiply.
What we want to do is have overall tiling.
This texture coordinates is going to act like a gateway
so that Unreal knows our intentions,
and it knows that whatever I connect to this,
it's going to lump things in such a way
and understand that I'm using this for UVs.
I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to keep my finger
on the S key.
I'm going to call this tiling.
This is my overall tiling.
And you can say, if you want to,
you can call it like tiling overall.
And I'm going to connect that into the B channel
and UV coordinates and connect it into the A channel.
I'm going to set this to one
to make sure that my tiling is on.
Next, this is a micro set up here,
or I should say macro,
what's controlling the whole set.
What I want now is to have a little bit more
of a micro set up,
where I'm controlling things on the U and the V.
So I'm keeping my finger on the S key.
This is going to be my offset U.
I can duplicate that control D,
that's our key for that.
And I can make this offset V.
I want to make sure that both of these are on.
So make sure the one is on for each.
There we go.
But to be able to be able to do,
to get this to work correctly, I should say,
to be able to be able to do this,
we want to use a thing called a append vector.
So I'm going to type in append vector.
What this does,
it allows us to be able to actually
have a secondary control.
And we can pipe this into an add or multiply.
So I can grab this UV offset, plug it into each channel,
grab this offset here and plug it into the B channel.
And now if I want, I can choose,
let me hit the hotkey A and left click and add,
hit my finger with the M key and left click or multiply.
Now the difference between these, if I did add,
things would shuffle and stay pretty linear,
straightforward with no size changes.
And I'd have to connect this here
and have to connect this here.
Or if I want, I can do multiply.
And I prefer multiply because it scales it a little bit
and can maybe hide some of the imperfections
after the texture.
So I can pull this into the A channel
and pull this into the B channel.
And then I grab each one of these
and put it into the UV slots for each one.
And then I hit apply.
With those plugged in,
we're going to make sure that you hit save.
I just hit apply.
And then now we look at our instance
and you'll see we have UVs all ready to go.
Now again, each one of these should be in a group.
I didn't do it because just to save time
that we went over in the first class,
but you can now see down here, the UV,
the offset U, the offset V,
and you'll see it scaling and then the overall tiling.
So again, using that and the multiply or the add
can determine how that's going to shuffle.
And I can show you really quick.
I go in here and then switch this to an add
for both of these and then apply.
We can now go into here and change things.
And you'll notice it's a lot linear.
There's no stretching going on.
Now it does make it so it repeats more.
So it squishes it, but the other way around,
multiply has a little bit more of a scale connected to it.
Well, that's it with this lesson.
In the next lesson,
we're going to take a look at creating masked materials.